j'ai passé mon année de césure l'an
dernier dans une zone de guerre
c'est à dire au début j'ai commencé mon
année de césure me disant je vais faire
des stages c'est à dire j'avais trouvé
un stage dans une rédaction à moscou ça
devait durer trois mois puis finalement
ça s'est assez mal passé avec aa
d'action et au bout d'un mois où je peux
virer voilà ça c'est des choses qui
arrivent
pour une question de désaccords sur la
ligne éditoriale il s'était assez pro
russe était une réaction francophone
basée à nantes et dans la foulée on va
résider mon visage j'ai vu des amis qui
m'ont dit enfin si j'étais à ta place
j'irais vendre des pitchs donc j'ai pris
mon billet de train pour kiev depuis
moscou et je suis allé en ukraine y
avait pas besoin de visages ça c'était
le début de mon aventure ukrainienne qui
au final la durée dans le temps un peu
plus d'un an
donc au total j'ai passé quasiment way
un nom en ukraine et
dont trois mois en zone de guerre aux
côtés séparatistes et là où on s'attaque
à la question brave new world en fait
c'est aussi on assiste aujourd'hui à des
nouveaux types de conflits ce que je
veux dire c'est que ce qu'on a vu en
ukraine vous vous suivez l'actualité de
l'europe de l'est c'est votre cerveau de
dire vous avez dû en bouche au cours de
vos études
on a vu ce qu'on appelle l'émergence
d'une guerre hybrides alors c'est un mot
sur lequel on s'interroge encore est ce
que ça existe vraiment le concept de
guerre hybride mais il faut dire
effectivement que ce qu'on a pu en
ukraine s'était d'abord dans la crimée
une invasion qui ne disait pas son nom
avec l'apparition sur place de soldats
russes osk sans emblème avec un l'état
russe qui refuse de dire nos soldats
sont ici une annexion en bonne et due
forme
et puis ensuite dans l'est de l'ukraine
dans le donbass on a vu des milices a
priori les personnes qui s'arme
eux-mêmes puis ensuite on a vu
l'apparition de matériel militaire de
plus en plus lourd donc d'abord des
kalachnikovs ensuite progressivement des
tanks anciens depuis les temps qu'un
moderne des systèmes d'armement tiers
et tout ça a pris l'aspect d'une guerre
de tranchées qui aujourd'hui à rennes
dimanche
selon les chiffres de l'onu qui sont
souvent sous-estimés et ça pose une
question en fait c'est comment est-ce
qu'on bosse dans cet environnement il ya
des nouvelles formes de conflits
est ce que ça implique des nouveaux
forme de reportage de guerre ça me
semble logique
en gros il y avait une propagande qui
venait avec la game reid l'a guérie mais
l'on peut dire c'est oui c'est
l'association de forme de guerre
conventionnelle et non conventionnelle
c'est à dire d'une part oui les gros
temps quasi à la taille davaï davaï et
ensuite des actions de guerre 6 1
si berne avec du hac âge en large et en
travers
mais aussi une énorme effort de
propagande est ce qu'on a vu au cours de
cette de cette gare ont du grain
on a vu le déploiement d'une propagande
qu'on avait jamais eu avant côté russe
avec la mobilisation de tous les tous
les médias nationaux de beaucoup de
médias privés aussi est véritablement
parfois de l'invention d'information
complètement délirante
ou la manière de présenter les
informations qui étaient complètement
délirante donc ont surnagé dans un océan
d'informations soient biaisés soit
inventé soit complètement fallacieuse et
il fallait se repérer là dedans
le seul briand a priori c'est d'aller
sur place
parmi les exemples on à me souviens à
l'été 2014
il ya eu le cas comme ça un reportage
qui parlait d'un enfant qui avait un
enfant de trois ans qui avait été
crucifiée par par les soldats ukrainien
en place publique
bon bah j'en ai ils sont allés sur place
ils ont libre que personne n'a été
crucifié c'est juste la propagande pour
dire à quel point les sandales craignant
auraient été des monstres de faire un
truc pareil
il ya eu en septembre l'apparition sur
les chaînes de télévision russes de
l'info disant qu' on aurait trouvé des
fosses communes dans les créneaux que
les soldats les soldats ils craignent en
fait massacrer des gens et fait des
fosses communes et donc au début les
séparatistes disent oui il ya quelques
dizaines de cadavres après une chaîne de
télévision parle 2,44 et le 1er octobre
sergueï lavrov
rémy nice parle de 400 cadavres 400
cadavres ça fait du monde
il semble que s'investit international
qui est venu sur place qui a enquêté en
fait il ya eu neuf cadavres
la majorité d'entre eux des combattants
et 4 effectivement été victimes
d'exécutions extra judiciaires de la
part de
de l'armée kényane s'est déploie mais
c'est pas 400 cadavres
et donc voilà enfin de grosso modo
qu'est ce que ça change trois
journalistes de travailler dans un
contexte de guerre hybride où il ya
cette espèce de de non dits sur le
déploiement des forces d'une part mais
aussi de de grande machination
médiatique pour vous soigner
l'implication des forces soient
diaboliser l'adversaire qui encore une
fois sont pas des choisi nommé qu'on a
vu à une échelle jamais vue en ukraine
avant mais je dis pas que les ukrainiens
ce sont des anges non plus effectivement
eux aussi ont employé une certaine forme
de propagande mais pour des raisons qui
sont assez nombreuses notamment le fait
que les médias les médias ukrainiens
parti n a diverti d'oligarques qui ne
suit pas de stratégie cohérente y avait
eu de grandes stratégies progrès niel de
diabolisation de la russie dans les
médias ukrainiens ou alors moins grande
échelle
bon tout d'abord faut parler d'un truc
c'est qu'on dirait ce cas une nouvelle
forme de reportage de guerre c'est quoi
le reportage de guerre maintenant ça me
rappelle un moment avec un ami qui était
correspondant de libération
c'est faut imaginer en moi on était tous
les deux à donetsk dans un espèce
d'hôtel un peu
que chico's en 4 étoiles sympa où on se
retrouvait mais c'était pas où l'on ne
sait pas où loger en ça coûtait
s'emballe la nuit on n'avait pas la tune
en mai en tout cas c'était sympa on se
retrouvait là pour travailler pour par
des coûts et pour discuter donc partout
dans le partout dans le lobby il y avait
des mecs gendarmes des businessmen un
peu louche de prostituées dans
l'ambiance d'une d'une zone de guerre
dans un hôtel chic tout ce que la région
compte de plus le plus festif et en
discutant aux aînés mais que tu crois
vraiment qu'on est de remporter le gain
en nombre
enfin est-ce que le fait d'être là
actuellement ça fait de nous des
reporters de guerre mais lui ça faisait
quatre ans qu'il est en ukraine
ça faisait quatre ans qu'il couvrait
d'actualité et il aurait déjà pu penser
que ce pays en paix puisse basculer dans
la guerre
un jour moi je les voulais c'était un
mode j'étais là j'ai même pas mon
diplôme d'école de journalisme
autant vous dire on va reporter de
guerre j'y crois pas une seconde car
effectivement les exigences sont les
mêmes pour le reportage de guerre comme
ailleurs ils ont d'objectivité de
respect des sources
donald et c'est a priori il n'y a pas
grand chose qui diffère vous connaissez
votre clausewitz vous savez que la
guerre est la continuation de la
politique par d'autres moyens
comment on peut comprendre une guerre
s'il ne comprend pas le contexte
politique historique culturelle du pays
dans lequel on se trouve
avant d'être reporter de guerre il faut
être reporter sur la zone qu'on connaît
aucune lumière est la même
donc on se dirait oui monde pendant la
guerre à tout ça il sait pas mais juste
on est juste là parce qu'un conflit il
faut le faire mais en poudre
l'ukraine voilà et puis on a vu
apparaître des trucs s'est dit voilà
enfin les dangers d'un toc ce sont les
mêmes partout
on a remarqué effectivement il y avait
des différences entre le risque de se
prendre un obus sur la tête me suis
retiré dessus effectivement que le
respect des sources n'étaient plus
justin vaguement que si jamais on
mettait le nom d'une personne ne pouvait
se faire tuer dans un article et ça nous
est arrivé à certains d'entre nous
d'avoir une source qui disparaît ça
m'est arrivé personnellement
puis on a remarqué dans ce contexte de
guerre hybrides y avait quelque chose de
nouveau si c'est quand même pas de
réellement nouveau mais le journaliste
est de plus en plus mis en cause dans sa
neutralité dans la mesure où
l'information est devenue un élément de
guerre bat mesure où l'information est
devenue une arme le journal filmé le
vecteur de cette information est un
vecteur de de munitions quelque part
l'information est devenue cruciale dans
ce genre de conflit donc notre
neutralité constamment remis en question
bon me demander tout le temps si
championne gestion donc je suis en
étions dessus
jean-marie français le blabla mais
fallait fallait se prémunir contre ce
genre de risque et ça nous est arrivé à
tous de se faire plus ou moins chahutée
séquestré blessés que ce soit par les
séparatistes tous par les ukrainiens
donc notamment
un épisode peu glorieux du
contre-espionnage des chrétiens qui m'a
mis quatre heures dans une cave avec un
makarov sur la table 10 rebonds alors
qu'est ce que tu fous très bon et on est
reparti pour annie parce qu'ils sont pas
complètement débile mais mais voilà et
on a remarqué d'autres trucs c'est
curieux il y avait un nouveau un nouveau
risque en fait pour les journalistes qui
apparaissait c'était de se faire enfumer
sur des questions techniques
alors ça a l'air de rien comme ça mais
un autre exemple il y avait un
journaliste américain qui est venu nous
voir un jour dans le même ramada le même
hôtel voilà on est en train de boire
populaire longue journée on se repose et
bien nous voir comment ça je suis choqué
il nous dira j'ai une histoire qui
pourrait être tous nous faire tuer et il
nous a tout de suite raconté ce que
c'était donc on avait tous se faire tuer
superbe nous a dit il ya le sv où les
services de renseignement ukrainiens qui
m'ont donné un document secret et qu'il
dit grosso modo que les séparatistes en
train de construire une bombe sale alors
pour que ces liasses pour ceux qui
savent pas une bombe sale c'est
simplement penser simplement compliqué à
ferme c'est une bonde conventionnelle
donc en explosif avec enrobé autour des
éléments radioactifs
le but est une arme de destruction
massive enfin une arme de terreur en
tout cas le budget car exploser ça
imaginez manhattan après ça enfin le pib
américain est divisé par deux c'est
l'idée grosso modo c'est que les
séparatistes est en train de construire
une arme de terreur massif qu'ils
allaient peut-être larguées sur kiev
ça m'a paru complètement débile comme
hypothèse parce que pour assembler ce
genre d'armes il faut un niveau
technique
ces gars là n'avaient pas la russie
n'avait aucune envie de les laisser
faire joujou avec des armes radioactives
et puis un moment facile à trimballer
jusqu'à kiev à rien il ya une sacrée
trotte km2 d'eaux nièce jusqu'à jusqu à
kiev
le tout en trimbalant avait une arme de
destruction massive discrètement non pas
croyez le ou non l'article est paru dans
newsweek et dans times mais c'est en
fumée c'était complètement enfumée donc
voilà fallait pas regarder ça et c'est
là qu'on a compris en fait les nouvelles
exigences pour les journalistes dans les
zones mais bien aujourd'hui s'il faut
connaître la technique il faut connaître
le matériel fossard distincts il faut
savoir distinguer un temps qui sont d'un
autre temps que c'est tout bête angle
mais prenez l'exemple du vous souvenez
du crash du même âge 17 juillet 2014
un avion vole tranquillement au dessus
de dubaï
tout à coup un missile éclate 298 main
la russie et l'ukraine qui se renvoient
la balle c'est toi qui l'a abattu non
c'est toi
bon c'est un secret de polichinelle
on sait que c'est la russie qui est
enfin on sait que c'est un missile russe
qui a battu l'avion le missile est
partie du territoire croate
mais il ya une telle une telle campagne
de propagande que ça complètement
on n'a pas su au finalement ont failli à
une vraie campagne informationnelle et
au terme de sa finalement les gens se
sont dit oui c'est peut-être les
ukrainiens à sa tête les russes en fait
suffisait de regarder les détails
techniques suffit enfin suffisent non
mais en regardant un peu les détails
techniques on sait que le seul appareil
le seul le seul système de défense anti
aérien capable d'abattre ce genre
d'avion s'était un système je dirais pas
russe mais quand même et on a vu des
trucs amusants on a vu sur la fiche
wikipédia de cette arme que le lendemain
du crash le plafond bâtir de larmes
n'étaient plus 10000 m enfin parmi le
maître mais 7 mm un hacker russe avait
modifié l'isf et la fiche wikipédia pour
dire d'en regarder ça peut paraître
cette arme parce qu'elle tire pas assez
haut pour abattre en avion n'est
qu'elles sont malades et finalement en
fait ça nous a tous étaient plus ou
moins utiles ce genre de nouvelles
compétences
quand on est en zone de guerre on
acquiesce que j'ai en acquiert ce que
j'appelle des compétences de boy-scouts
c'est à dire
on est confronté à des armements
quotidiennement via un gars il va nous
montrer une arme il me dit ça c'est une
catastrophe
ok il ya un mec qui va te donner un
gilet pare-balles il dit ça ça va
arrêter des balles de set 62 mais pas
d'émail de neuf si ce n'est pas bon pour
et après ils nous expliquent la bla bla
et de fil en aiguille on apprend à
reconnaître les temps qu'on apprend à
connaître on acquiert une petite
connaissance militaire du méthane
perdre l'âme la technicité en stack ça
devait être utile mais en fait c'est
derrick des choses comme ça qu'on a pu
démontrer l'implication de l'armée russe
dans l'est de l'ukraine
un exemple c'est j'ai fait un article
c'était en février 2015 sur l'aviation
des séparatistes séparation n'ont jamais
entendu parler de l'avion dans les eaux
l'ukraine mais des séparatistes disais
oui nous avons des avions les mecs ont
mis en place
il avait sorti trois coups tout comme ça
il s'était installé des roquettes en
dessous ils sont dit ça y est on a une
force de frappe terrifiante
on va pouvoir faire mes gamins de
l'armée ukrainienne bourse était de la
com mais c'est intéressant quand même
parce que pour faire rouler un avion fou
du carrousel et ça pousse pas dans nos
moeurs ou déjà ça c'était un signe
intéressant
par ailleurs il fallait des pièces de
rechange tout ces trucs là c'était des
pièces de musée donc je me suis rendu
sur place je suis allé voir l'aérodrome
et j'ai dû le garder dans l'allée un
système antiaérien qui s'appelle le
pense et qui tient systèmes antiaériens
très perfectionnés développé par la
russie en 2011 et jamais exporté
qu'est-ce que ça foutait là le truc
c'est que si jamais si j'avais pas été
capables d'identifier celles à ce
système entier rien j'aurais pas pu dire
c'est les russes
vu que la logique en fait grosso modo
des ukrainiens enfin des pro russes
échappent pas de dire nous avons cet
armement parce que nous l'avons saisie
aux ukrainiens pour de la bataille est à
dire les ukrainiens ont fui ils ont
laissé leur temps pour les a repris
c'est difficile de prendre aux
ukrainiens en armement qui n'ont jamais
eu rien logique donc voilà c'est là en
fait que je pense que pour ce genre de
conflit
aujourd'hui il est une des exigences du
haut du reporter de guerre et c'est pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui je pense le terme
reporter de guerre justifie c'est qu'il
faut acquérir cette technicité pour
acquérir cette connaissance de
l'armement et du fonctionnement des
arbres et puis il ya un autre truc qui
était intéressant c'était les réseaux
sociaux les nouvelles technologies c'est
je sais pas si vous connaissez
ainsi que s'appelle bel 4 mai qui a
sorti pas mal donc être récemment et en
fait les mecs ne vont pas sur le terrain
ce qu'ils font c'est issue sur les
sources
ce qu'on appelle l'open source ils
suivent les les réseaux sociaux et
suivent les seules filles qui sont
postés en ligne
il voit un mec qui postent dans cette
fille ils ont à donetsk
et puis ils vont regarder sur son profil
il voit que le mec soldats dans l'armée
active selon les choses et c'est comme
ça qu'il ya eu les unes des enquêtes qui
est à mon avis une des plus belles
enquête qui a été fait sur la guerre en
ukraine c'est un truc fait par nice où
il ya un journaliste de vice très
talentueux qui a qu'à trouver un profil
sur ce contact qui le facebook russe
profite d'un soldat russe qui étaient
déployés dans l'est de l'ukraine y
poster énormément de salif sy ce garçon
il postait des séries partout dans les
yeux d'ukraine donc le journaliste weiss
a créé une page il aller dans les
extrêmes il a recréé une page contact
et il a fait 17 filles au même endroit
que ce soldat russe et après il lui
envoyer la page dédiée alors des
commentaires évidemment il a refusé de
commenter mais c'était assez une preuve
encore
l'obligation d'un bien et c'est ce genre
de chose qui permet en fait de traquer
des armes n'a frappé fort ce qu'ils
disent ils aujourd'hui dans les conflits
hybride est en fait ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce
savoir la est transposable d'un conflit
à l'autre par exemple prenez la guerre
en syrie
jean catteau ci a enquêté sur la guerre
en syrie il ya des enquêteurs russes qui
sont n'est jamais allé en syrie ont
réussi à démontrer rapidement
l'implication de l'armée de l'armée
russe en syrie le déploiement
moi même j'ai fait une enquête sur la
manière dont dont les russes avaient
organisé leur déploiement là-bas
simplement avec des soutiens en ligne
qui permet de suivre en direct le trajet
d'agen ces trucs qui sont disponibles et
vous voyez il ya plein d'avion en temps
réel que ce soit l'avion de barils
jusqu'à berlin ou où le transporteur
cargo qui trimballe des flingues du
kazakhstan jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'attaqué en série et ça ça
permet de faire énormément dans quatre
ans donc on s'y est ce que vous réalisez
que aujourd'hui un des cartographes les
plus renommés sur la guerre en syrie
c'est un adolescent néerlandais c'est un
mec de 17 ans qui s'appelle thomas van
linden qui depuis deux trois ans dans sa
chambre
celui des relevés des relevés
géographique suit l'évolution du conflit
et conflits de tout ça il fait des
cartes avec des couleurs marines et ce
en ligne 70000 followers
enfin c'est des interviews partout et on
voit de plus en plus ce genre de choses
et celle à pouvoir parallèle qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on a à la fois
l'apparition de formes de guerre qui
sont qu'il mélange de conventionnelles
et non conventionnelles qui sont ce que
papier libre il et on a par ailleurs
l'émergence de journalistes puis aussi
dans que l'hybride qui est qui reste sur
des formes conventionnelles il faut
aller sur le terrain il faut continuer
d'aller sur le terrain mais par ailleurs
les enquêtes convoi récemment avec ce
genre de choses montre qu'on n'a pas
nécessairement besoin d'être sur le
terrain par ailleurs que les deux se
servent
c'est un nouveau type de guerre
un nouveau type de journalisme de guerre
mais l'essentiel c'est de parvenir à
chaque fois à suivre l'évolution de ces
conflits pour voir s'adapter au mieux
possible et dénoncer les excès qui
pourraient être commis et les empreintes
aux lois internationales comme on l'a vu
l'an dernier
jones
[Applaudissements]